人事戦略を見るとその会社の未来が見える
でもっと言うとその社長の考え方が理解
できるその雪だるの核と一緒だよねその
1番の中心になるそういう人材をまず
見つけてくる青木サの人生経営哲学100
回聞いたら豊かになる
話はいえ本日はですね経営に欠かせないの
は採用ということでま特に採用担当者に
ついてお聞かせいただきたいと思うんです
がどんな人うんを担当に置くべきかという
ことを教えていただけますでしょうかうん
[音楽]
うんそれはも非常にシンプルだよねどう
いう人材を採用したいかということに対し
てその採用したい人材がこういう人と一緒
に働きたいと思ってもらえる優秀な人材を
採用担当者にするってこですで世の中で
多くの経営者が間違ってるのはお前営業で
ないからちょっと人事でもやっとけとかね
もうこれ全くねピンボケのね意思決定なん
ですよ人事というのは最も重要な仕事で
ジャックウェルチというねGのCEOは
ですね経営者の仕事の7割は人事だと言っ
てるんだよね私はやはり優秀な人材の採用
と育成そこに投資をしてきたから今の
アチーブメントがあるわけですよだ戦略を
見るとその会社の未来が見えるでもっと
言うとその社長の考え方が理解できるだ
からこう人をコストと見ているのか
インベストメント投資として事業は人なり
と考えてるのかこれがですねいわゆる人事
担当にどういう人を置くかによってまそれ
もわかるっていうことだよねだから
やっぱりまコンピテンシモデルという企業
のモデル的人材能力要件を満たしているえ
優れた人を人事の担当者に抜擢するとこれ
がポイントだと思いますありがとうござい
ますなんか逆にこうこういう人はすべきで
はないという人の特徴ってありますか
[音楽]
うんまそれはあのフミーのやつダメだよね
まずそれからなんだろうその人事の仕事を
1つの自分のキャリアを今後こうステップ
アップしていくための踏み台ぐらいに考え
てるような人間とかね過去アチーブメント
でもいたんですよ何人か人事の仕事さして
ほしいそしたらやめません私はもう全く
それには影響受けずにまダメだとうんま
やめそうな人間は人事はできないんだよと
あのそんなことを大体交渉すること自体が
お前人事向いてないよと
うん人事ををね任せる人間っていうのは
経営者の福神なんだとトップの真の右腕と
して一緒に理想の会社を作っていくそう
いうコミットメントを持ってる人間以外は
もう人事はさせないと言ったことがあり
ますようんまこの辺のところは大事な
ポイントかなありがとうございますはい
高い基準でその人採用担当者を置こうとし
た時になかなか社内に該当する人材がい
ないうん
[音楽]
うんそうねこれは非常に大事なポイントだ
よねアチーブメントは2004年に深層
採用に踏み切って2005年から毎年
ずっと一定のま人員を採用してきて今の
アチーブメントがあるんだけどもあの4大
卒の非常にこう優秀な子に任せました私は
ま早くから社会出てるし大学生の気持ちっ
て分からないわけある意味ではだからその
大学生の気持ちのわかるついこないだまで
大学生だった子に責任者をさせて採用の
仕組みを考えさせて任せたんだよねだから
そういう人材がいなければ最初はもう中途
採用で自分がやはり率先してま採用をする
しかないよねその雪だるの核と一緒だよね
その1番の中心になるそういう人材をまず
見つけてくる任せるまもしくは外部の
コンサル会社に頼むってこともあるんだ
けどま正直ね経者自身が人事戦略を持って
なかったら安易に外部の採用コンサル会社
に丸投げてのやめた方がいいと思うだ
アチーブメントも採用のお手伝い何者か
もちろん今までもずっとさせていたけれど
も経営者に私の講座出てもらってしっかり
と会社のビジョンを描いてもらって学生
から見て魅力的な会社5年後10年後20
年後ビジョンエンロールって言うんだけど
ねその将来のあるべき姿から逆算して今は
こんなレベルだけど将来はこういう会社
こういう社会を作ってきたいので仲間に
なって欲しいという採用をしてきてるので
まずそのコアはやっぱり経営者だよねだ
から最初は経営者が自分が率先してやって
あはま右腕役員に採用担当させてその後は
ま大学生採用できたらその採用した大学生
優秀な子だったらその子に任せるそういう
優秀な子が採用できないようだったら
やっぱり役員が地道にやりながらま最初は
1人2人からして徐々に大きくしていくっ
ていうのがまステップなんじゃないかな
そんな風に考えますありがとうございます
うん最初の1人の優秀な担当者に出会う
ためのなんかコツとか秘訣ってあるんです
かねあーこれはね私は運が良かったんだと
思いますうんそんなのはコツも何にもない
わな私の場合は選択理論に共感した人材
たまたまですね私が選択理論を学んでいく
中でその学会の活動の中で出会った子を
口説いたんでだからまあなんだろう
アチーブメントの存在理由に共感したこと
出会えたっていうのが1番ラッキーだっ
たってことだよねまある意味では運かも
しれないよねテクニックではないですよね
だ一般だったら多分アルバイトから入れて
この子はね将来性があるなとか価値観が
あるなとかいい子だなと思ったら口説いて
正社員にしていくでその子と一緒になって
人事の仕組みを考えていく
その時は外部のコンサル会社の力も借りる
まそんな風にしてやっていったらいいん
じゃないです
[音楽]
かシンプルに会社の未来を託すわけだから
やっぱり優秀な人材をそのポジションに
置く正直ね中小例祭企業って売上が欲しい
のでどうしても売れる人間は営業の方に
回してそういう人事だとか企画だとかの方
にはなかなか回せないんですよでもあえて
言うと人事はやっぱり会社の未来を一緒に
作っていく部署なのでやっぱり優秀な人材
をそこに配置するとこれが良い会社になる
秘訣だと私は考えて37年ま新卒採用を
始めたのは2004年ですからまそこから
まあっという間にもう21年かなあそう
いう歳月が流れてるわけだけどもまか思っ
てます今85%は新卒でねえ頑張ってくれ
てるんでみんなその中から役員が育って
ますからそういうことですね頑張って
いただきたいと思います是非あのコメント
欄にも是非ねコメントよろしくお願いし
ますあとあのチャンネル登録まだの方は
是非えおかげ様でね多くの方にチャンネル
登録をしていただいて先日3万人も超え
ました是非皆さん積極的にチャンネル登録
よろしくお願いしますJA